new surveillance video shown to CBS News
reveals the final moments before an 18
month old girl fell to her death from
the deck of a Royal Caribbean cruise
ship chloe Wiegand was being held by her
grandfather salvatore anello while the
ship was docked in puerto rico in july
prosecutors have charged him with
negligent homicide our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is here
and David I know that you saw this
horrific video you also spoke to the
family's attorney we did we did the
interview last night look the video is
going to be a key piece of evidence in
the criminal trial that attorney is not
yet releasing the video publicly but we
asked to see it to better understand
exactly what happened you see what
appears to be 18 month old Chloe cross
over to the side of the ship and she
stands right in front of a big bank of
windows that appears to extend for
probably 20 yards a man the attorney
says is her grandfather is seen
following her he toddles right behind
her as if he's watching her this picture
was given to us by the family attorney
who says this is an identical
representation of the railing which is
about I'd say a foot in front of the
actual glass on the side of the ship
the surveillance video that I had a
chance to look at appears to show the
grandfather he comes to the railing he
looks over the railing for just a second
he then reaches down he picks Chloe up
and he appears to hold her over the
railing not outside the window but just
over the railing the family attorney
says the grandfather didn't realize
there was no glass directly in front of
him within five seconds
you see him holding Chloe and then she
falls about a hundred and fifty feet
below here his family attorney Michael
Winkelman why did he lean forward with
her she's sitting on the wooden banister
why did he then lean forward with her I
think it's pretty obvious why they
leaned forward and that would be so that
you could get a better view what do you
say to the fact that he raised her and
put her on this banister which the
cruise line might argue was not meant
for young children to be sitting on it
if that was the case and they wanted no
one to Siddhant they should say no one
should sit on it there's no sign that
says that there's no one warning no
nothing counselor it may be hard for
some people to believe that the grandpa
didn't know
that that section of window was open how
did he know that there was glass the
only way that you could prove or
disprove anything that Sam said is based
on the video and based on his testimony
those are the only pieces you have of
evidence you have there are no
eyewitnesses there's no one else who's
come forward to tell any different story
so all you have is Sam's testimony his
story in the video after Chloe fell out
of the window the grandfather dropped to
his knees according to the family
attorney and he yelled out loud I just
dropped my child I thought there was
glass I thought there was glass we have
reached out to the cruise line Royal
Caribbean for comments so far we have
not heard back they have called this a
tragic accident and since a lawsuit is
going to be filed they said they'll have
no comment beyond that it is a tragedy
no doubt and the question is is it
reasonable for a parent to have expected
there to be glass in that window from
what I've heard from you
it seems pretty reasonable to me I've
yet to see any kind of anything that
would overturn the family's account the
family is not going to decide whether
they want the video to be released
publicly who that's that would be very
hard because that means it exists
forever online yes this is the worst day
of their lives that's a tough one but
but punishing parental error adds a
legal insult to what is already in
irreparable injury to this family Tony
it is interesting again it's about 20
yards of glass right from floor to
ceiling and then there's that one
section well when you look at the
photograph of it it looks pretty obvious
it's not there but you don't know from
from the grandfathers angle what he saw
one thing we can all agree on is tragic
accident David thank you very much